Brittany's new fashion campaign is body
goals as her ex Kevin Federline might be
taking her back to court plus Idol judge
Luke Bryan jumps to Katy Perry's defense
after that controversial kiss and Darren
Criss jumps at the chance to perform
with instincts at JC sha say hey guys
I'm Danny direct oh and this is the
daily Denny and can we talk about
Britney Spears in her first-ever fashion
campaign that's right the 36 year old
pop icon went to work [ __ ] and is now
the new face of high-end fashion line
Kenzo Britt posed in the brand's very
youthful collection on the streets of
Los Angeles and admitted to Vogue the
shoe was a little weird for her because
she was rockin promiscuous clothes on
the street instead of a studio like
she's used to now the mom of two also
added she's toned down the fashion risks
these days out of fear of embarrassing
her kids but can we all agree Britney
looks better than ever and you know what
she's also making more money than ever
Britney has done very well for herself
recently and now it looks like her ex
and baby daddy Kevin Federline wants to
collect her coin et has learned k-fed
wants more child support at least double
the amount he is currently receiving and
he could take Britney to court if he
doesn't get it now in case you forgot
the part-time DJ has full custody of
their two boys 12 year-old Shawn Preston
and 11 year-old Jaden he currently
receives about $20,000 a month from
Britney and child support so why does he
want more well source close to Federline
Kozik quote appropriate giving the
significant increase in her finances
okay so yes Britney made like a hundred
and thirty five million dollars from her
huge Las Vegas residency
there's the 24 fragrances and this
latest endorsement deal with Kendall but
still it doesn't sound like Kate that
needs more child support it sounds like
he need a budget plan meanwhile a source
close to Brittany tells ET the singer is
already paying for most of the boy's
expenses beyond the child support adding
we want to know where that 20k is going
show us receipts you want receipts well
good luck to you keV don't forget
Brittany still under Aiken
servitorship her dad Jamie still
controls for finances though better
lines attorney tells us he's the
conservator of Brittany not the
conservator of Kevin okay so all of this
does beg the question how are Britney
and Kevin getting along
while we're told it's a cordial
relationship and kevin has always
allowed her to have more time with the
boys make sense because he's got six
kids to keep track of q tom was kind of
salty about this story
speaking of Katy Perry was in a bit of
hot water after this surprise kiss right
on the lips of then 19 year old
contestant Benjamin glaze during his
American Idol audition well apparently
young Benjamin got more than flustered
telling the New York Times it made him
uncomfortable immediately and he wished
it could have been saved for his first
relationship well then later clarified
his comments to ET calling the kiss
harmless
well now Katie's fellow Idol judge Luke
Bryan is jumping to her defense after
that headline making smooch fortunate
did stuff like that turns into a you
know a story that big I watched an
actual interview where we're being the
kid that was involved you know he he
said he was cool with everything here
right and I got a back Katie on that you
know she's in there working hard and
great fun great fun TV making fun TV at
the end of the day me and Lionel and
Katie and Ryan are our you know our
hearts are in the right places in
Benjamin's interview with ET he said he
didn't think the I kissed a girl singer
had any bat intent quote honestly it was
show business it was just kind of fun
and games obviously it's got a huge
amount of publicity and I am more
thankful for that than not you know in
fact when we asked how her kiss stack up
then admitted he has nothing to compare
to but would guess a 7 she seemed like
she knew what she was doing alright then
well moving on to former Glee star
Darren Criss who is amazing an American
crime story by the way you recently
turned back time and shared the stage
with JC SH as a and our Bryce Sandra
found out how the two teamed up
seeing this instant classic looks like
that happy like somebody please somebody
else needs to see this with me any
witnesses
[Applause]
you and JC shah's a how did that come
together uh yeah you know I I threw a
fun little st. Patty's Day party and we
had a lot of really fun guests and we've
thrown a couple of them they're always
very dl very no social media when i
found out who was gonna be seeing with
us i was like yep get your phones out
this is the coolest thing ever
it's around the 20 year anniversary of
that first album that NSYNC put out so
there was kind of a 90s theme to our
party so we were celebrating a great 90s
record great 90's artists and JC's
amazing voice and I can't believe you
said yes I was like I was trying to be
nice and have him sing something else
cuz I don't want to you know put him in
a corner and he's like no I'd rather do
something know the words to I'm like
fine I'd be very happy you make a lot of
people at this party very happy so that
was very cool meanwhile JC and the rest
of the guys will finally be getting
their star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
that's happening on April 30th to all
you insane fans all right we also will
have more with Darren Criss he shared a
message to fans who think his butt
deserves an Emmy that's right
head over to ET online.com slash daily
Diddy for that piece of gold and I'll be
back tomorrow with another daily deed
that's me my face and my hair thanks for
watching
you